so ranae I'm sure this is your career
millions of scripts come your way what
was it about this project that you
couldn't say oh there's a list of about
2000 things how much time we have number
one boy I tell you but I wish we had
more scenes I really did oh that was
such a delight sharing the day with this
guy right here that was ridiculous I
quite enjoyed it too actually it's funny
because I was taught to be my first day
wasn't it yeah it was actually my second
from last was extraordinary I mean for
me there's compartment responsibilities
which I'm sure she's very aware of it's
like you're playing someone real but I
also felt the pressure I knew that she
was halfway through this thing to turn
up and do it but but feel that there is
a kind of history there yeah is that
your experience Hollywood is getting
better slowly
well it's inevitable isn't it I mean the
younger generations of women are you
know coming of age and women of my
generation agency now we participate in
decisions that are made about the
trajectory of our careers and we have we
make choices and there's less ignorance
about the consequences of certain
choices that we make unless excuses now
that's true that's true and bringing you
to a whole new audience as well cuz
young people it may not hurt ever watch
this film which is unimaginable to
someone who grew up watching The Wizard
of Oz every year with the rest of the
country at the same time you know but
it's true we have different heroes now
because we don't share many cultural
experiences so it's wonderful to be
talking about someone who was a great
uniter now he was celebrated right by
generations and generations